hey youtubers is Charlie so there's
gonna be a breakdown of star wars number
one the new ongoing comic book that's
part of the new Star Wars Canon so they
have three new comic books coming out
there's a Darth Vader one two and a
Princess Leia one so I'll try to do
videos for all those cuz it only gonna
come out once a month the comics being
written by Jason Aaron who you may
remember from x-men schism he's also
wrote a lot of awesome Wolverine comics
John Cassaday is the artist and Laura
Martin's the colorist the editor I
actually actually happened to know the
editor Jordan D white I got to know him
a little bit whenever I was working on
comic book club back in New York that's
the the comic book podcast if you're not
familiar with comic book club it's
really fun that was actually how I got
started doing YouTube videos I got
started working on a show called comic
book club it was called pulp secret but
that's something completely different as
part of all that I just I had the
opportunity to meet a lot of comic book
creators a lot of comic book editors it
was a lot of fun it was a really
interesting way to get into YouTube I'm
doing something just a little bit
different with these types of videos so
please give me some feedback I'm just
gonna make them look a little bit
different since there are comic books
it's a little more visually oriented so
I'm trying to have a little bit of fun
and I'm doing a comic book giveaway like
a comiXology gift card that I'll explain
at the end of the video so we'll just
start by saying full spoiler warning for
Star Wars number one what I'm gonna do
is show a couple panels just so you guys
can see and you guys will read the text
like I won't read the text on the screen
just so you guys have a chance to see it
on your own and form your own opinions
before we start talking about it so here
we go so the funny thing about this
intro sequence is that it virtually
mirrors episode four you start off in
space with the shot of the ship but it
also mirrors a little bit of Return of
the Jedi you have been cleared for
landing it's an older code but it checks
out
just because it's Star Wars and you know
it's fairly traditional to include lots
of references to the original trilogy
look forward to a lot of that but it's
not gonna overpower the story with
references they're well-placed but they
are pretty obvious if you're looking for
them the basic premise of the comic is
that they blown up the Death Star so now
they're going on the offensive so now
they're just taking it to the streets so
to speak taking it to the Star Lanes I
also just like how that the fun thing
too is that they're visiting the
Karelian system which is pretty bad as
it's not something we've seen a whole
lot of on screen definitely not in the
movies yet
as you can see this is a nice play on
what this is gonna end up happening
later and Return of the Jedi like I said
this is right after the first Death Star
blew up so that's like six years away
Jabba's palace is almost six years away
the funny thing about this panel is it
really invokes that Guardian scene where
Chris Pratt is talking to Djimon Honsou
haven't you heard of me
my name's star-lord ah screw it I know
it seems like Chris Pratt's character
might have been influenced by Han Solo
because he is a han Solo type character
but in the Marvel Comics Star Lord Peter
Peter Jason quill however you want to
think about him first debuted in 1976 so
that's like right around the time where
George Lucas would have still been
making that first Star Wars movie but
now that Disney Marvel Star Wars is all
the same thing you know some of the
writers are just playing around with
that just having a little bit of fun I'm
sure Chris Pratt would be totally
humbled by being compared to Harrison
Ford
so I just love the fact they have chewy
sniping in the distance
his wookie rifle is like a slight
modification on the bow caster and then
you see Princess Leia like off to the
side wearing the Lando Calrissian
disguise from Return of the Jedi so many
visual references this is actually a lot
of fun I feel like it's just a bonus of
the artwork looks amazing this is
probably one of my favorite lines in the
whole comic here you just have Chatty
Cathy Threepio in the background who
just won't shut up with probably one of
the most iconic Star Wars lines of all
time from any of the movies I totally
have a good feeling about this I think
it'll go well
so if you play the games are you big up
on EU cannon you know that these Thai
fighters are actually made by senior
fleet systems this is like the Ln model
of TIE fighter that I mean there's a lot
of different variations like Darth Vader
has his model of TIE fighter that's
called the Thai advance then there's the
Thai defenders I mean it's like it's
like a whole Thai series but they're
basically like the cut and paste
vehicles of the Empire
just like crank them out on an assembly
line thousands and thousands at a time
you
so finally their plans revealed like
this is essentially a slightly modified
version of their infiltration of the
first Death Star they're gonna try and
blow up the biggest factory that the
Empire has in the Karelian system it
would their production of TIE
fighters and weapons is essentially
so the only thing I really want to point
out at this point I mean obviously
they're they're working on their plan is
Leia's outfit like she's not walking
around in her white bed sheet I always
think it's funny when Carrie Fisher
talks about making the original films
and she talks about how she wore a
bedsheet like all over the galaxy in
that entire first movie
as you can see you know some nice
references to the garbage compactor from
the original Death Star I also like the
idea that the Karelian system like the
Star Wars universe is just really dirty
in general
it's a part of the fun of these new
comics is exploring Luke's like first
steps into using the force like he
hasn't met Yoda he's not even close to
becoming a Jedi but he still has some of
the teachings that obi-wan Kenobi gave
him before he died on the Death Star
you
so you have to remember at this point
that like that the romance between
Princess Leia and Han Solo has it really
turned into anything yet like it's still
in its very nascent stages it's not till
Empire Strikes Back that they really
acknowledge their feelings for each
other and even then it's only at the end
of that movie so so right now he's like
completely dodging any questions like
what are you really doing this for well
yeah very clearly he has something for
Leia so he's trying to help her out but
he I think inside he's also trying to do
something good it's like a male version
of the hooker with a heart of gold
there's something really twisted about
their character but they do want to be
good like they do want to do something
positive
so second best reveal the comic Darth
Vader just happens to be around Jabba
was going to negotiate with the Empire
to buy weapons and ships we just hadn't
met the negotiator that the Empire was
going to send but I think he just shows
you how seriously that the Empire takes
the Hutt's and then he picks up the
stormtroopers and uses them as a human
shield with the force and then just like
crashes the structure around Chewie
this is just so much fun like Darth
Vader's like wait what the deuce I
always feel like the Darth Vader
character works better when he's not
talking it's like when you watch the
behind the scenes on the original
trilogy and you hear David Prowse
talking in that British accent it's like
you immediately understand why George
Lucas thought it'd be a good idea to use
James Earl Jones as the boys
so I don't want to give too much of the
comic away but you should all run out
and buy it like there definitely some
some very iconic moments and then you
have to remember that in addition to
this being a continuing comic they have
the Darth Vader comic coming out next
month and then in March they have the
Princess Leia comic so I actually I have
previous for those two comics right now
that all actually I'll just play so you
guys can watch
you
so because these are coming out so
infrequently what I'm probably going to
do is I'm just gonna do my giveaway for
the comics so I'll start my comiXology
gift certificates in these comic book
videos because this is the first one and
there's like a $10 minimum on comiXology
gift certificates so there'll be three
people that will be winning $10
comiXology gift certificates so just
explain what's gonna happen going
forward with these since they only come
out once a month even though I'll be
doing like three of these a month
whenever we get to like the end of a run
or like the end of a big arc I'm gonna
compile all the issues and do a
breakdown of the entire story arc so
that means at the end of this year like
before the movies get started they'll
probably conclude this initial run I'll
do a full video for all 12 issues in the
same for the Darth Vader comic and the
Princess Leia comic the giveaway will be
ongoing all you have to do to enter that
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's real simple so while
we all wait for like the next Star Wars
coming to come out you can click here
for all my other Star Wars Episode 7 and
related videos and you can click here to
get ready for Game of Thrones which is
coming up pretty soon there'll be a
trailer for that really soon thank you
so much for watching so let's all
high-five I will see you guys this
weekend